Arielle is gonna tell us about fall yeah
thank you sorry for tricking you and
changing the title after you came in but
but this is a I'm gonna focus on a
specific Universal snark that was
developed after I submitted the abstract
and title so this is a this was a nice
project joint with of probe Mike the
company I work for protocol labs and
Aztec protocol that is working on
improving privacy and the etherium
cryptocurrency so right so I'm going to
describe to you a proof system called
plunk and basically there's two steps
one I'm going to convert convince you
that all you need to care about is doing
this thing called a permutation check or
permutation argument this this wasn't
new and then I'm gonna show you I think
this in terms of constants this is where
we get a lot of gains is that
permutations are easier to check on
multiplicative subgroups and I'll I'll
show you what exactly I mean so so so
let's start with the the first thing so
so I'll be remind so what's our setting
here
so we're setting we have some circuit at
some arbitrary non uniform circuit
I'll assume it has fan in two like
addition and multiplication gates and
the fan out is instructor is arbitrary
and what I'm interested in is I'm
allowing some pre-processing but I want
sort of what what we've been calling
here our Universal trusted set up
meaning that if there's any like private
randomness in this set up I want sort of
the private randomness part of the set
up to be only dependent on the circuit
size
okay so let's let's look at a specific
example say we want to prove that I know
a b c such that a plus b times c equals
7
so since powerpoint is not free and the
cryptocurrency prices have gone down I
haven't been able to pay for it so the
drawings will be manual so right we're
looking at this circuit we have one
addition gate I think of it as the first
gate and one multiplication gate right
and we're making you want to prove some
statement of knowledge about this
circuit so now think of right we have
sort of six with repetitions we have
sort of six values involved we have two
gates and each gate has three associated
values the the left wire value right
wire value and output value so I've got
these these six values and let's see
what what do we need to check about
these values
so we have first we have what we can
call the gate checks right that l1 plus
r1 equals o 1 and L 2 times r2 equals o
2
and next we have what we can call copy
checks or the wiring checks so right
these values are not independent we know
that the the left of wire of the second
gate is the output wire of the first
gate so they should be the same so this
corresponds to the check oh one equals
l2 so it's just one check here but since
the fan-out is arbitrary right this
could be a big thing like it 1 wire
could be the left wire of some arbitrary
subset of gates and the right wire of
some other arbitrary subset of gates and
we would need to check that all of those
values are equal the third thing we need
to check is what we've been calling in
the last few years the public input
checks so right we want it we want to
check that the o2 in is equal to 7 that
the output is equal to 7
so I'm going to half ask you to believe
me but I think it's intuitively clear
also may be given a NYX talk yesterday
that basically the gay checks and the
public input checks are in a sense easy
and the the hard thing is the wire
checks right said differently if the
prove er was nice enough to sort of
align things correctly and we just have
to do these component wise checks then
our job is easy and the hard thing when
especially you're talking of general
non-uniform circuit is these wiring
checks
so I want to show you this is an idea
that started with the gratin in 2009 at
least first time I saw it that all these
copy checks we need to do it can reduce
to one what we can call permutation
check so so how do we do that so we had
these six values left right and output
wires let's write them all in one long
vector and now right what did we want to
check we wanted to check on this fact
vector that the second and fifth values
are equal so so now let's let's look at
the permutation that keeps everything in
place but does a cycle on switches the
values two and five so right it's easy
to see that we have oh one equals l2 if
and only if this vector V is invariant
under this permutation signal
and it's not hard to see that suppose we
had many of these copy constraints so
what does that mean it means this vector
of length 3 n when we have n gates all
these copy constraints that are going to
divide the vector into these disjoint
blocks and if we take a permutation that
does a cycle on each of these blocks
this one this thing V equals Sigma V
it's exactly going to capture all the
wiring copy constraints of the circuit
single donation you could check that all
these constraints hold by so you're in
this
well the verifier but you can write the
each equality constraint between two
values as write single will be so at
least in a straight in a sense we are
that is what these works are doing to a
degree but right at least the
straightforward way of doing that would
would give you linear verify verifier
time because the verifier has to be
through the model where you can specify
you know combination of the values of
the written here the very far just needs
to check it's zero
yeah the question is how I don't think
I'm not sure in general you can move
from that model to a model to like to
compile it to something where the
verifiers is succinct
I think what's what's going on in these
works maybe is that when this linear
combination happens to be like a
polynomial thing like our R squared - R
to the n when you get to that case then
you you can compile it to a protocol
where the verifier is fully succinct but
I'm not sure you can do that right now
with
okay all right we're half done part one
so for part two of the talk permutations
are easier to check on multiplicative
subgroups so let me start by showing you
an idea from from work of Bayer and Graz
that basically lets us reduce a
permutation check to one sort of product
to a local product check in the sense so
let's look at like a specific
permutation right so just the right
shift and suppose I've given you vectors
of length three and you want to check
that B is the right shift of of eight
so the first thing what we're going to
do is we're going to choose some the
first thing we want to do is to get to a
place where suppose the prover is
cheating B is not the right shift of a
we want to get to a point using
randomness where as multi sets a and B
are different
so how are we gonna do that we're gonna
choose some random beta in the field and
we're going to sort of add according to
the alleged permutation be satisfies
we're going to add random multiples of
beta to the different elements so so for
a we're just gonna add you know a 1 plus
beta by order sort of a 1 plus beta a 2
plus 2 beta and and have a 3 prime be a
3 plus 3 beta and so and for B we're
gonna add random multiples according to
the permutation we're checking so we're
gonna add to be 1 3 times beta to be 2
beta + 2 B 3 2 beta and now so so if
really B was the right shift of a then
right then we've added two identical
values identical multiples of beta so as
multisets like the primes will also will
be the same the same multi-sets and what
you can show using the Schwarz if lemma
is suppose that B is not the right shift
of a then with high probability the a
Prime's are different as a multiset from
the B primes
alright so that's that's the first sort
of step of the brand bear Grodd
randomization
so far
okay and now right we will eventually
what we want to do we just want to take
the product of all the A's product of
all the B's and just compare that but
right it is possible that two sets are
different as multi sets but when you
just take the product of everything here
and everything here you get the same
thing so now we want to have another
level of randomization to eliminate that
possibility so this this part is simpler
we just choose a random gamma and now to
all the elements all these six elements
we just add this random gamma
and now again you can using the Schwartz
if ulema you can you can show that if
you started with things that are not
equal then the corresponding products
now will whoops will be will be
different sorry for that that should be
not equal
yeah
all right so now a bit of change of
gears sort of we've we've said okay just
check circuits we didn't need to check a
permutation to check a permutation we
need to check sort of products and now
sort of change of gears I want to give
you some framework somewhat related to
other frameworks we've seen the
holomorphic algebraic homomorphic
protocols Aled meant it talked about and
the polynomial IOPS Benedikt talked
about I want I want to give you another
abstraction that I've found very useful
in this paper that I call a polynomial
protocols so so what what is the what
are these protocols look like well so at
the beginning there's a pre-processing
stage where the verifier chooses some
some set of polynomials of degree
smaller D that that he likes
now during the protocol P the messages
will of P you can think of them going to
some ideal party I and they're also
these messages are going to be
polynomials of degree smaller than D if
if P tries to send something else to the
ideal party the the protocol is aborted
and rejected the messages of v2 P can be
arbitrary but but we'll always think of
public point protocols where the
messages are just random bits or field
elements
okay so we've run this protocol P sent
all these polynomials and now what
happens at the end of the protocol the
verifier needs to accept or reject so
what the verifier will do he'll choose
some polynomial identities and ask the
ideal party do these identities hold
between the pre-processed polynomials
and the polynomials the approvers sent
during the protocol and and the verify
will accept or reject
according to if these identities held
okay so why why am I allowed to look at
this ideal idealize protocols is because
of the polynomial commitment schemes
that Benedict and others talked about
basically using the the the the katay as
a virtual Goldberg polynomial commitment
scheme if you're willing to swallow a
trusted set up basically what you get
from from kzg together with just the
Schwartz using the Schwartz they pull
them on random evaluation points that
you can compile this such a protocol to
a real protocol real under strong non
phosphoryl assumptions like the algebra
group model where each message of P
which was a whole polynomial will be
translated to just a constant number of
bytes
yeah nf SPL stands for a number field
sieve paranoia level so according to
that you'll take elliptic curve elements
that are either 32 bytes long or 48
bytes longer or 64 bytes long
alright but if you've like many of you
you've worked on PCPs or proof systems
you'll maybe be thinking this looks nice
but it's not typically exactly what I
what I what's comfortable for me because
right typically in PCPs and proof
systems we don't exactly check
identities between polynomials we check
that they're the identity holds over
some special set so if you're I have the
thing just for you this is what we call
eight ranged polynomial protocols and
what what do I mean by this so now you
can you fix some subset of your field
that you like and these this ideal
protocol will work in the same way
except that in the end the verifier will
not ask the ideal party do these
identities hold as polynomial identities
he will ask do these identities hold on
all the points of this special set age
questions so far
and and and here's a nice thing that I
think shows like a nice use of this
terminology is that it's very easy to go
from one to the other so say okay I have
a polynomial protocol where I'm checking
identities and I want to simulate one of
these eight range protocols so the nice
thing you can do that very efficiently
in the sense that say the age range
protocol you're simulating checks many
identities so you can convert it to a
polynomial protocol that checks just one
identity and you're only going to have
one additional message in the polynomial
protocol compared to the range protocol
you're simulating so how does this work
you can you could probably guess so
suppose for example we had an age range
protocol where the verifier wants to
check two identities on H right so each
of these peas it's some P of the F
Center G's so how are we gonna simulate
the age range protocol well we're just
gonna run it and but then when okay the
point where V wants to check the
identities he's gonna do the following
he's gonna choose a random coefficients
alpha 1 alpha 2 and now he's going to
ask P well you know send me OK after
you've you've seen these sent send me
some some polynomial t and now V is
gonna check the identity alpha 1 times P
1 plus alpha 2 times a 1 sorry P 1 plus
a 2 a 2 P 2 equals T times Z H where Z
is the polynomial that that vanishes on
on H and you can see using I mean it's
easy to prove that right if we know that
something vanishes on H if and only if
it's divisible by Z H and we also know
that if you have a few things one of
which does is not divisible by Z H then
a random combination of them will not be
divisible by
eh either so this this is why this thing
is correct
when you say identities P 1 P 2 NH these
identities are phrased as something
equals zero on edge yeah it's like some
P is some polynomial so it's some P
composed inside with all these FS and
G's is zero on all points of H yeah
all right so now right what did you want
to do we wanted to check a permutation
what does this mean in the in this
polynomial world
so now let's let's fix some permutation
Sigma and let's let H be some subset of
a multiplicative subgroup of the field
so H is powers of some element alpha and
suppose P has sent some F in in some
polynomial F so suppose we're in the
middle of one of these polynomial
protocols or range protocols so f
intuitively think of it as this this
vector of all the polynomial whose
values on this this subgroup are like
all these wire values so so right if we
go back to where we came from sort of
what we want to do is is that F is
invariant under this Sigma meaning that
for every I F of alpha to the I is equal
to F of alpha to the Sigma
so I won't without going over the exact
details I think you can believe after
seeing this big rot reduction we did it
on vectors and not polynomials that this
can be reduced to the following scenario
where we're in the middle of one of
these range protocols P has already sent
some two polynomials F and G to this
ideal party and now he wants to prove
that the product of F values on H is
equal to the product of G's values on
each
right so what's going to happen in the
pre-processing you're going to have some
polynomial let's also abuse notation
call it Sigma simply such that Sigma to
the of alpha to the I is Sigma I now
no wait no so I want I want some
polynomial that will encode my
permutation so this is like the abusing
notation calling them both Sigma but so
let me call this FC now I'll call it
Sigma I think it's clear not oh you know
it's so confusing I guess yeah let's
call deaf Sigma so right this is some
polynomial that encodes the permutation
Sigma and so really what I'm where did
the permutation go so this product check
I'm not gonna do it on my original F I
had the original F I want to check the
permutation on but yeah but I'm actually
going to define F prime to V F so I'm
going to have to I'm going to have one
like F Sigma which encodes my
permutation I'm going to have some F ID
that encodes the identity permutation so
just this thing and then from my F I'm
going to define F prime which is the
polynomial F plus beta I'm going to
choose some random beta gamma the
verifier I'm going to then like define
these two polynomials and G prime equals
F plus beta F Sigma plus gamma and then
I'm going to do this product check that
I'm doing here on F and G I'm actually
going to do on these polynomials
okay and now so right so the the
question is how do we do a range
protocol that checks this product thing
and it's really using all this
terminology it's really simple so so
basically we're going to have some help
auxiliary polynomial Z that will sort of
accumulate the values of F so right z f
of alpha is just 1 and then Z F of alpha
to the AI accumulates the values of F
the until not including I so Z F of
alpha to the AI is going to be the
product of the values of F up to I minus
1 and similarly we're going to have
defined such a polynomial Z G that's
going to accumulate the the values of G
and now I claim that this product check
it reduces to these checks so what are
these Elle's these Elle's are like the
Lagrange polynomials so L by L I I mean
the polynomial that an alpha to the I
gives one and an alpha to the J gives
zero for for J not equal to I so that's
what I mean when I write here Li and the
nice thing is that when H is like at
least Udet even just a dense subset of a
multiplicative subgroup these
polynomials are going to be very sparse
and the verifier can compute them by
themselves so right so what what what
are the checks that we're going to do
well you want to check that really this
okay so we're right the provers sent
this CF + zg that are supposed to be
sort of these things that accumulate the
values of F and G and we want to check
that that's what they really are
so first we're going to check that the
the accumulators of F and G they both
started at the same point like the
Honest party is supposed to have this
value b1 but it doesn't matter so this
is this check L 1 of ZF is the same as L
1 of Z G
oh it's a good point
wonder if that's something we we need to
correct you're right but not zero
that's a yeah a good point is that hard
to do I need another constraint for that
personnel me sorry
yeah I'm wondering because like the the
more straightforward thing is to check
l1 ZF equals 1 and L 1 zg equals 1 in
separate checks i wondering if and i
condensed them to 1 i wonder if
okay and then we write these two these
two checks right check that really ZF is
accumulating point by points so so so
this is like the where the simplicity of
these multiplicative subgroups compared
to similar permutation checks that that
worked in sort of different frameworks
comes in that right it's just this check
Z F times F equals the next value of Z F
which is very conveniently just z f of
alpha times X and then we do the same
thing with with CG okay now we know we
start from the same place ZF + Z gia
really accumulating values of F and G so
we just need to check that they end up
in the same place which means the
product of values of F and G are the
same and this is this check Ln of Z F
alpha X equals Ln of zg l fakes
so these identities have to hold for all
xmh yeah so this is right so this is in
this abstraction it's right we just want
to check something by point so you could
think why not just check it on the point
but we're in this sort of abstract thing
where no no no you need to have your
checks on all of H otherwise in the
compilation but the nice thing with
these lagrange things is when you when
you do this thing Li times like F minus
G it exactly corresponds checking it on
all of H corresponds to just checking
equality on the point I
all right so what do you get all out of
all this this stuff so what do you get
if you use the forget example a 381 bit
curve which is the standard what you get
from the standard paranoia level from
number field sieve algorithms you
currently you're gonna get 700 byte
proofs for statements about about
circuits where the trusted setup is is
just done once for all fan and two
circuits of n gates the prover
complexity is going to be usually it's
usually dominated we're still in the
middle of writing the implementation so
we need to check but it's it's dominated
by these twelve and g1 explint
exponentiations right we're in this
pairing setting so we have this cheap
rubgy one this expensive group g2 and
but what's interesting here is this is
also similar maybe to two Nick's talk
these types of constructions they write
they totally separate sort of the gate
checks and the wiring checks and the
nice thing is that the wiring checks are
extremely batch Abul right what do I
mean by that right you have a bunch of
vectors and you want to check for all of
them and you have one permutation which
describes the circuit and you want to
check for all of them that these all
these vectors are invariant under this
permutation right so you can just check
that some random combination of these
vectors is invariant under under this
permutation and what what that ends up
giving you is that if you're looking at
some amortized setting where you're
doing at once a bunch of proofs for the
same circuit then sort of your marginal
cost for proof ends up being compared
very comparable to the state-of-the-art
Snorks where the the setup is per
circuit
summer is the one where these the same
entities producing all this groups yeah
it has to accepting where you got there
somebody else's proofs and you have
taught you so it was either information
to simplify yeah yeah so I don't know
how to do how to aggregate arbitrary
proofs of other people these numbers in
this last line is only when you yourself
are doing a bunch of proofs yourself so
you're proving different statements for
example for the same surfer the same
circuit and the same inputs
okay so what is the wind should I finish
when I can because I have because now
it's the bonus material so I can either
do or not do the the bonus material
according to but you talked about the
Colby sex right but there's also the
gate X right so yeah oh yeah this this
700 by 1012 fan it incorporates it yeah
so this set of public license yeah it's
the total it's a total proof sighs yeah
yeah intuition about why you can you
don't know how to do they help setting
can retain hindsight there is a lot of a
shared techniques
between the sonic and this particular
improvement like this yeah checks but
somehow along the way is a nice
motorization property both false I'm
just and I'm cures for the only opinions
about which other techniques you're
using makes it difficult so I didn't
really until you mentioned it I didn't
think about trying to do a help setting
so yeah it could be
I I did not consider that that until you
you mention it
yeah
okay so I maybe I'll you know release
you for lunch and if if anybody wants I
can show in the the bonus material is
just this KZ sorry no unfortunately N
and is the total number of gates I think
this is sort of the next interesting
open question like to because in these
trusts of the purse circuit you get sort
of the addition gates for free so to be
able to do that even partially with a
universal set up I think that's the next
interesting open question in this
direction
okay so I'll I'll release you for lunch
if anybody once I can personally show
him that this black box the kzg scheme I
can I'd be happy to to show it
personally to any anyone interested it's
a really cool simple scheme
[Applause]
okay thank you Thanks